we are always excited about our guests
but we are particularly excited about
our next guest it's actor director
producer movie star Elizabeth Banks she
starred in TV shows and movies you know
we're talking Hunger Games Pitch Perfect
Modern Family and her new movie is
called call Jane which she plays a 1960s
housewife named Joy who faces a
life-threatening pregnancy Joy connects
with an underground group of women who
work to provide abortions before Roe v
Wade was decided it's a movie inspired
by a real life group based in Chicago
and in the clip you're about to see Joy
promises to teach the women everything
that she has learned about performing
abortions
when do I I'm going to teach you
anybody who wants to learn
and I'll stay as long as it takes to
make you as good as anyone can be
and then I'm going to leave you to it
I will raise as much money as I can to
keep you going to keep you safe
because that's what I can do for you
in return for
all that you have done for me
and as it turns out I know plenty of
stuff shirts with money
okay
and Elizabeth Banks joins us now uh good
morning good morning uh the movie's a
Triumph thank you so much yeah it really
is it's it's a drama that brings you
back to historical reality yeah um how
much of that reality did you know
existed did you know this group existed
and what Drew you to the project
honestly I did not know about the Janes
before I read the script I read the
script about three years ago now you
know we we plan to make the film before
the pandemic
um and before obviously the Dobbs
decision from this Summer that
overturned Roe v Wade so for me when I
first read it I just thought oh this
will be such an a great way to honor a
little piece of history of these very
revolutionary women in Chicago who
pre-row you know provided really caring
and safe abortion care when at a time
when so many women put themselves in
very dangerous desperate situations in
order to not be pregnant and
obviously with Dobbs we in so many
places in America are are getting back
to that
moment and there are real Janes
everywhere Now everywhere it's almost
Eerie to me and surreal that it's
happening at this particular time while
it's so relevant for women today how do
you hope the movie will be received what
do you want people to be the takeaway
because I I never heard of it either and
I thought oh what a nice piece of
history and now we're looking at it's
staring Us in the face and it's scary
yeah it's well it's it's now no
announced recent history yes
um you know we we really de-politicized
abortion Health Care in the film as much
as possible really tried to recenter it
as the health care that it is
um my character I think is really
relatable Joy is a woman who never
thinks she'll have to seek out abortion
Health Care is pretty judgmental of
people who do
um you know and really opens up
this experience opens up a greater sense
of her empathy I think and and her um
ability to have a better understanding
of a path that people walk whether
you're going to walk it or not and I
think for me that's what I want people
to take away from the movie The
Experience was horrible because the
doctor was such a jerk he was so cold
yeah you go from someone who's laying on
that on that on that Gurney with with
him not caring about what you were going
through then performing the abortions
yeah that was real that that really
happened the women
um one of the things I love about the
film too is I think there's a big
mythology around abortion Health Care is
that it's really scary you might die I
mean they they're certainly activists
that yell that at women who are going
into clinics yeah and the fact of the
matter is that an abortion uh is safer
than most dental uh experiences it's
safer than a colonoscopy
um in the movie they describe it as like
scooping out pumpkin seeds
Okay I mean that's a good one now you
know now you take two pills at home so
it's it can be self-managed at home for
most American women who are going to see
but that line underscore is an important
point you de-politicize abortion in the
movie but you don't shy away from the
act and from the repercussions yeah it's
a big part of it was that a tough
decision I mean one of the key scenes is
your character undergoing the procedure
you know I think it was important we
didn't want to shy away from it the our
director Phyllis Naj who handled the
material so beautifully really wanted to
present I think the experience for women
um who were at a time when they had to
rely on men for their care and you know
that said that's kind of new history for
thousands of years women took care of
reproductive Health whether it was
pregnancy and childbirth and Midwifery
and all of that and you know we we've
really gotten away from that for a long
time now we've allowed men into that
room and even with the abortion bands
it's like I don't want to be in the
doctor's office talking about planning
my family with my husband my doctor and
like Lindsey Graham yeah
you've mentioned the word conversation
plenty of times and you've had
conversations with your sons yeah about
sex and very openly it's one of the
toughest things to do when you have
teenager or even I have a 12 year old
girl yeah um why do you think it's
important to be honest and not shy away
well I think it's interesting that you
say it's difficult because to me that's
that key right there why is it hard for
us in our generation what what shame are
we carrying that it's so hard for us to
say to our kids to talk about their
bodies sexuality sex which is like
everyone's gonna have sex
on what we will learn and we are and we
are living in a society where shame and
stigma surround these issues so much
that a lot of lies get told to people I
mean especially young people and it it
presents sex as like scary and you're
gonna get STDs and you're all going to
get pregnant and you should only wait
until you're married it doesn't it's not
people's lived reality right like it
wasn't my lived reality like I hate to
tell you but I had sex before I was
married yes you know and I'm you [ __ ]
yeah well and that's the other problem
that was it yes right so shame and
stigma that's it like if you're doing
anything outside but that's just not
people's live reality everyone knows it
it yeah and we don't want that for our
kids I want my kids to grow up have safe
healthy relationships with their
Partners yeah you know that's it and I
want them to treat women respectfully of
course forever of course so and I want
them to enjoy it yeah yeah
you know 99 of this thing I have was not
to make babies right it was it'd just be
fun it'd be intimate yeah it's called
pleasure pleasure it's like like working
out just getting reps the producers are
like um Elizabeth Banks thank you now
Carl Jane is an absolutely great film it
hits theaters on Friday you are the best
and one of the best in the business I
seriously mean that but Nate exercise is
not fun it reps yeah it depends it
builds the endorphins I get it you know
what I'm trying to say that's the other